Over the course of this class and in the forums,
a number of you have asked me about research
or what I do to nominally push forth the boundaries of human knowledge
and make the world a better place.
And now I'd like to give you the chance, the opportunity,
to participate in just such a project.
Oh, fellow travelers on this voyage of discovery,
I stand before you, hat in hand--well, metaphorically, at any rate--
asking for your help, for your participation.
Let me set the stage for you.
Imagine that you have a job as a computer scientist
and you have a program that you'd like to work on.
It could be some Excel macros to make a better spreadsheet.
It could be a game you've always wanted.
It could be an assignment from your superior.
Probably you will think hard about the problem--
that's what we hope everyone does--find examples online, write your code,
debug it, and then, typically later, you may have to make some changes.
All of these stages--except perhaps thinking about the problem--involve reading code.
It turns out that in industrial practice, more time is spent reading code
than on any other activity, especially writing it.
By some estimates, up to 70% of time is spent just reading existing code.
And as a result, the readability of code has a huge impact on productivity.
Readable code doesn't just look good; it has an economic impact.
That makes it unfortunate that we really do not understand code readability at all.
We have some intuitions for natural language readability--
when something is at the 3rd grade level versus the 7th grade level--
but we'd really like to understand code readability more.
I think that one way to do that is to ask people like you, ask people in the real world,
"What do you think? Is this code readable or not?"
and from that build a formal mechanical model that we can use
to evaluate existing pieces of code and make representations.
The largest existing study on code readability--more than 70%
of the work of industrial software development--involves only 100 participants.
I think that we, free online education, can do better,
and I'm going to need your help.
The survey we'd like you to participate in consists of a number of examples
of snippets of code from real-world programs.
The survey is completely voluntary and anonymous.
We're not going to store any identifying information.
Instead, we'll present you with a number of snippets of real-world programs
written in either Python, Java, or CUDA.
You're already familiar with Python, but you may be less familiar with Java or CUDA,
a language for programming graphics cards.
You don't need to be an expert. You don't need to be familiar with those languages.
In fact, you don't even need to have heard of those languages.
We're very interested in gathering your intuitive notions of software readability.
So we'll show you a number of pieces of code,
and after looking over each snippet, you'll rate it on a scale of 1 to 5,
where 1 indicates less readable and 5 indicates more readable.
The exact notion of readability we are leaving up to you.
For example, perhaps you'll see a snippet like this and decide that it's a little less readable.
Perhaps you'll see a snippet like this and decide that it's a little more readable.
We're really interested in what you think about this subject.
So the survey takes about 15 to 30 minutes,
and it's totally anonymous and confidential.
We're not going to store any important information
that would help us trace these numbers back to you.
It's not related to this Udacity class in any way.
In fact, it's not worth extra credit. It doesn't influence your grade.
It's solely to try to make the world a better place by increasing human knowledge,
by helping us to understand when code is readable and when code isn't--
a really important part of software development.
I realize that many of you are quite busy; you've got other things to do.
Not a problem at all.
But if you are interested, if you're not busy, if you have a few moments to spare,
I would really personally appreciate it if you would take them and help us out.
Even if you're not particularly comfortable or an expert with these languages,
you're just as necessary.
Those data points are critical.
So if this isn't worth extra credit, why should you participate?
A number of people on the forums have suggested that,
based on my reasonable radio announcer voice, I should consider singing a bit more.
These people are clearly doing their best to flatter me,
because my singing is not all that and a bag of chips.
But the graduate student who is leading this project,
who is helping me out, is a pretty good singer.
So what we have agreed to do or what I would be happy to do
is if we're able to get the required number of participants--
if 1000 people help us out--we will happily sing the song of your choice.
We have no shame if it will help us push forth the boundaries of human knowledge.
So if you like Irish music, [singing voice] "Oh, it is the biggest mix-up
"that you have ever seen. Holy mo, me father loves Nikita Kruschev. Holy moly me."
If you like Bollywood musicals, [singing voice] "Pretty woman, dekho dekho na."
If you like it un Francais, [singing in French].
If you prefer it in Spanish, [singing in Spanish].
If you like Japanese, [singing in Japanese].
Or if you just like more English or American folk music,
[singing voice] "Lemon tree, very pretty."
We'll do anything you want.
Whether it be the theme to The Muppet Show
or whether you'd like to hear me butcher romantic Mandarin songs,
[singing in Mandarin], we will do it.
Start a thread in the forum and vote for your favorite.
Participate in the survey, and I will happily do almost anything
in order to make the world a better place with future research.
Please participate if you do have a few minutes,
but it is by no means required. Thank you.